[Music]
[Applause]
welcome now each and every one of us is
a consumer and more than ever
organizations are having to understand
what we want when and where in order to
compete for our money and grow their
business
increasingly that means not only
providing the products and services we
need better faster and more creatively
but doing so in a way that meets our
expectations around ethics and
responsibility
as all businesses target this
responsible growth they may find ideas
and inspiration in some unexpected
places
today we're discussing what business can
learn from health and fitness we'll
discuss the power of innovation and the
importance of putting the customer their
goals ambitions and passions at the
heart of what you do
and i'll be discussing these topics with
kat mccusker pwc uk partner for
responsible growth darren hardman vp and
general manager at amazon web services
uk and ireland and sami adame ceo and
co-founder of fit
well i'm really excited to talk to you
all i'm going to start with you sammy
first i think we all know that it's
obvious that business
wants to pursue growth but i think now
it's all about responsible growth isn't
it for me it's quite a simple uh
definition of responsible growth when i
applied to fit i think that
if you can genuinely say that the more
your customers use your product and
service that is better for their daily
lives and if it's better for their
physical and mental health then that
that is responsible growth and if
all of the product development decisions
that you
take
are to hit our mission statements just
to make fitness a habit for everybody
then
again that's going to improve people's
daily lives so for me that's responsible
growth and you know that's what we do at
fit
yeah responsible growth is is growth but
not at all costs you have to think about
the life cycle of the business and how
you operate and make sure that all the
stakeholders
great value from the the the
relationships that are built and the the
transactions that happen i mean i think
the whole role of how we're looking to
work with customers has fundamentally
changed it's now gone from being about
what the stakeholders once wanted and
the shareholders being the drivers of
profit to really starting to think about
what is that more meaningful
relationship we're looking to have we're
especially looking at that not just
across
customers as consumers but also what
that means for citizens students people
in the public sector as well as across
the different reach of place and purpose
as well and businesses had to really
focus on their purpose and their
societal impact and people are really
looking for that in the line of
responsible growth and it's no longer
just about profit it's about that whole
ecosystem and how they're going to
deliver on that
but is it tricky then to keep a
personalized experience um unique when
demands are changing people want
different things and you have to evolve
how you know how do you do that in your
business i mean yeah fit is a digital
first interactive home workout solution
the key element in that is the
interactive piece when we first founded
the business four and a half years ago
we realized that you know most most gyms
and most exercise centers didn't have
really a relationship with their
customer they would check in go and do
their workout and check out you you just
did not know what they were doing in
that in that one hour in that two hours
so the interactive piece you know with
wearables i think a third of the uk
market or a third of the uk population a
third of the us population have
wearables you know whether it's fitbits
apple watches chest straps
and using that data is absolutely
integral to personalizing that service
and the research does say that
you know consumers are much more willing
to give over their data if you're going
to give them back a very personalized
service the key there is the ethics of
how you hold that data
and actually it's not the tools and the
systems that
manage ethics it's the individuals the
leaders within organizations and so
having a code of contact around ethical
use of the data is just really really
important to give the confidence to
consumers and actually i think that
builds loyalty and do you think business
has really had to sit up and think about
this absolutely i mean we're all very
very aware of the cookie apocalypse
that's coming when we're you know we're
already seeing and experience it with a
lot of our apps on our phone when
they're asking you would you like to be
tracked or not tracked and given that
permission and just a few things
building off what's just been said was
how you use data is really really
important and it's not about what you do
with it it's why you're doing it so
historically we use data just to push
and push push more from a consumption
perspective now i linked to a lot of the
learnings we've had out of health and
fitness we saw like in the last five
years that over 59 of people have
embarked on some form of healthy
lifestyle be that diet 29 of that was
from march 2020
so you know this is how people are able
to consume things through multiple
different barriers and data and the data
also needs to be thought about in
regards to gdpr even within gdbr you can
do some fantastic insights and analytics
around data but also thinking about that
from a societal perspective those from
disadvantaged backgrounds those who may
not have access to the super fast
broadband in regards to consuming some
of the great technologies that are out
there but also looking at the disparity
and the leveling up agenda how the data
and insights are being used to affect
those citizens and customers as well
well with this huge focus on the
customer have we put the consumer in a
position of power are they in control
are they dictating how things are moving
forward yeah i think so i think the
consumer's been in control for a long
time if you go back 20 years you look at
the fortune 500 top companies only half
of those actually exist and it's because
they failed to respond to their customer
fast enough they failed to reinvent
their services or their offering and
other disruptors have come in and taken
their place and so
you know it's it's the core of what we
do at aws every day is very much focused
on the customer obsessing about their
needs listening to them making sure we
can look round corners so we can predict
what they might want for the future
and how does this fit in with health and
fitness for you sammy
again i think it comes down to the the
mission of what you're trying to achieve
i think look most people
they want to improve their bodies they
want to improve their minds and it's
really really hard there are lots and
lots of quick fixes out there and we've
all seen it six week abs eight week abs
two week abs drink this tea you're gonna
feel great
the reality is that
they're all they're lies essentially i
mean it's you're trying to get someone
to buy a product once then buy it again
and we all know that fitness takes time
it takes commitment and it's hard and
you know fit we're trying to solve a
problem which is to make it easier for
people we're trying to make people build
healthy habits and we're trying to make
fitness part of their lifestyle and to
do that you've got to you've got to be
truthful you've got to take people on
that journey you can't just say look
you're going to get there in six weeks
there's six key levers that at any time
the businesses need to be pulling on and
they go from experience to marketing to
sales to the service you provide pricing
of course will be there and innovation
and it's really understanding at any one
time which levers to use in organization
be that some of the stuff that sam is
saying with fit do you need to pull on
different elements of those to that
being with how we're looking at things
in healthcare with what the analytics
tell us but actually what does that
person need for an experience to be
really life changing for them and how we
help put them on that journey i think
customer expectations are continuing to
increase i think day in day out i mean
you know the expectations of you you're
scrolling you look at something for
three seconds and when you first
ordered an uber probably you're happy to
wait 10 minutes and now you probably
want to wait two i think customer
expectations are growing i think the
digitization of services is growing i
think you know sustainability and ethics
this is growing i think customers expect
more from the companies that they engage
with on i mean all the time i think
that's moving at a huge pace
i think we have to
as business we need to innovate we need
to look at trends i think it's also we
can't just say
this is what we're doing today that's
going to be enough we have to constantly
improve we have to constantly learn
constantly communicate so i know we
talked about data quite a bit i think
the communication with customers and the
actual
conversations whether that's
you know via social media through your
customer success team or inviting
customers in and communicating with your
business i think these are integral to
building long-term sustainable
businesses but do you think the pandemic
has accelerated these trends absolutely
organizations have been historically
quite inward-looking and they felt that
the customers were privileged to get to
engage with them with certain brands
from the luxury brands right down to
what we've seen with some of the fast
fashion retailers now people are very
much more ethically and socially aware
of what they want the pandemic has no
question accelerated the digital
transformation across
every industry and applied to
every conceivable use case it's it's
it's it's been really apparent from the
industry that i'm in and the customers
that i'm supporting in fact we we didn't
want to just take the anecdotal we we
surveyed 10 000 of our c-level customers
over the last six months and we found
that actually
the digital transformation has been
accelerated by about two years and five
months on average which is astounding
and you see it because
customers consumers end users their
demands changed dramatically overnight
with the pandemic and organizations had
to pivot quickly to release new services
or to change and evolve the services
they had now obviously from a cloud
perspective with the flexibility the
agility the scale up and scale down
capacity that cloud technology gives you
we saw that with our customers who had
invested in the cloud they were able to
do that quickly yeah it's almost like
adapt innovate or die in a sense it's
really
i think people were
literally overnight with thrust into
this okay what are we going to do
everyone's expecting us to be available
in their homes tomorrow you know we we
identified that trend in sort of 2017
the pandemics has basically accelerated
at such lightning pace what customers
expect but also
it's brought forward the inevitable so
it's just brought forward the the fact
that
you know you could work out at home and
you can get a great experience
we were one of the early ones in that
and then all the other gyms and services
like we need to do this as well and
customers went actually this is all
right i can get a gr i think that was
one of the big things as well
the quality of the service that you can
get in your home
or on your phone
was way way better than most people
expected i think that's really been
that's a big shift for me is that i
think the
yeah the quality of the service way
exceeded people's expectations then
again it has created long-term customers
it's no question fit you've you've
helped disrupt an industry and we've
seen this whole kind of plethora of new
digital disruptors enter the market and
put pressure on legacy providers and um
you know there's been a lot of reasons
for that you know consumers have just
demanded something different a pandemic
has come that has created a off enforced
a new set of demands but a lot of them
actually long term demands that have
just been kind of coming and appearing
and and putting pressure on the
traditional models and why we see a lot
of these new digital disruptors
appearing is because
the cloud is a
it's an amazingly low barrier to entry
so if you want to stand up a new service
and have access to all this data all
this technology artificial intelligence
machine learning
historically you would need to buy a
data center buy a whole team of people
put millions of pounds worth of
infrastructure and software in there now
you can turn it on with the cloud you
can experiment you can fail fast if one
particular customer offer isn't working
you fail fast you come out it's cost
little you spin up a new idea and that's
why reinvention and innovation is really
important because it's the digital
disruptors like fit that are bringing
that innovation to the market and
putting pressure on other business
models it's actually driven the
conversation that of reasons we cannot
change in so many industries and
particularly you know a lot of work i do
in public sector across education and
local authorities and central government
reasons why we can't suddenly became
within 48 hours we had to so it almost
took the conversation two years ahead of
itself and now we've gone from hybrid to
high flex working and how that's going
to work and how we're going to be moving
forward you know again that whole role
of ensuring that the customer is at the
center of that's going to be really key
and that really resonates i've seen this
new
confident set of enterprises that have
proved to themselves they can be agile
they can be flexible they can create
innovate experiment and push out new
services to their customers to their
users in a way that i don't think they
ever imagined they could and that's one
of the positives that we've seen come
out of this pandemic darren cat sammy
thank you so much
this has been a brilliant discussion and
i'd like to thank our guests
for sharing so many fantastic insights
and ideas and if you found this
interesting please do also watch the
other episodes in this series exploring
how business challenges are better
solved together